no no don't do it
as for reviewing food fight
nothing like bringing in the holidays
than by justifying the gym membership in
January I'll never use a pumpkin hot dog
on a pumpkin bun with pumpkin ketchup
though would it be prudent to possibly
dip it in some pumpkin whipped cream as
such a feat ever been done before how
was that oh shit
I'm late for this DVD review could I get
any heavier foreshadowing I mean look at
this the forest left right in the
shadows if we do this to all our props
they're gonna fade we'll just put you in
this case later hello I'm the Nostalgia
Critic
guy remember it so you don't have to
well it's the month of Halloween and you
all know what that means it's time to
celebrate a great writer by focusing on
his worst work it's Stephen King time
there's no doubt that Stephen King is
spectacular when he's good but for some
strange leads and he's even more
spectacular when he's bad at least when
it comes to his film adaptations for
years I've been mocking his infamous TV
mini-series but the time has come to
finally journey to the next level of
laughable hell his motion pictures and
what better way to start off in the film
he had 100% control of Maximum Overdrive
this is the only Stephen King story that
Stephen King himself directed hell he
glorifies the fact that you directed it
just look up a trailer I finally decided
if you want something done right you
ought to do it yourself I just wanted
someone to do Stephen King right that's
right there's no arguing someone
interpreted it wrong
no claiming that filmmakers just don't
understand King no saying that Stephen
King's work should be transferred to the
cinematic world or that Stephen King
himself wouldn't like it this time
around there's no excuse this is the
only time we'll ever see Stephen King on
Stephen King that is until tumblr is
born so sit back my Halloween ease and
let's see Stephen King done right I'm
gonna scare the hell out of you
this is Maximum Overdrive of course it's
only fitting that an author starts off
this visual medium with a butt ton of
reading nice and comment town eight days
there's a give me a reason why the
Earth's emitting a broccoli fart at the
same time and fittingly again King
starts off his annotation by doing what
most Stephen King adaptations do saying
fuck you to the audience Wow he just
cuts to the chase doesn't he even king
himself gets its customary cameo out of
the way honey
this machine just called me an asshole
obviously it watched under the dome as
the credits roll we see all sorts of
chaos go on as tons of machines come to
life and cause gigantic destruction
after gigantic destruction the only
thing that could possibly be more
awesome than that the greatest credit
ever put on any film anywhere
Oh God I have no idea what they have to
do with Stephen King but I am 100%
behind that credit it all makes up for
this one though it's somewhere in this
movie ac/dc decides to coach a hockey
team I wouldn't be against it
we then see a gas station where by far
the strangest fucking toy truck you've
ever seen in your life pulls in the
point of your toy company was to scare
the apple-juice piss out of your client
Elvin yeah I say you got a winner though
to be fair it is scarier than anything
in the Sam Raimi movies
well filling up on his nine dollars for
15 gallons of gas fuck you 1987 one of
the truck stop attendants played by
emilio estevez
talks to his boss played by passing them
now you want me to work for nine hours
and I'm gonna clock in for eight you
know what that star bees don't you on
parole boy either your ass belongs to me
it belongs to state of North Carolina
really a gold star means you're on
parole but the convicted paedophiles get
it Dora the explora sticker Thank You
blossom is Stephen King film so I can
act however I want and it'll fly but
within the truck stop
a young Deborah Wilson and dragged
notices the machines are acting up
ah the 80s when wearing a Twinkie in
your hat raise no questions whatsoever
apart from why the fuck do you have a
Twinkie in your hat
sure enough other machines start acting
up - an electric knife cut someone
vending machines spill all over the
place and yes there is even death by
soda at least I'm leaving behind a
hilarious obituary the little boy tries
to get away from Stephen King second
killer Cola machine he's ever written
seriously was it something the first
time it had to be repeated as we see
another boy get run over by a
steamroller now there is a controversial
cut here where it's said in the original
the boys had actually explodes but it
was too much for an r-rating in honor of
our sick obsession with violence we
should probably question more fuck it
I'm gonna show you the one frame that
made it into the film I think you can
see his eyeball shoots or his brain let
me have this we don't see a hitchhiker
played by the dollar store version of
Molly Ringwald pull into the truck stop
as the radio says everyone should get
off the road
why well judging by this couple it's
because a lijo Osmond is inbreeding
that's the only way you can explain why
he's somehow became two people Curtis is
he dead but you're Lee Smith by the way
the voice of Lisa Simpson and if you
think her character on that show can be
annoying take a listen to some of this
you know suddenly the idea of slitting
my throat with her spiky hair doesn't
sound that bad I just wanted someone to
do Stephen King right they end up
driving towards the truck stop where our
heroes are read who are checking out to
see if the trucks themselves have
apparently come alive be careful that
jack-in-the-box they forgot to crop out
might ruin the scare oh no it would have
been ruined even without it
so anybody in there nope no so the truck
has to adjust its rear view mirror in
order to see them mm-hmm I wouldn't mind
so much the idea that trucks have eyes
and are somehow in the driver's seat
area but do you have to do it on the
only truck in the goddamn movie that
literally has eyes isn't that kind of
throwing the truck Anatomy off of it
the little bully version of Kim grease
rides around the neighborhood realizing
that technology has officially come
alive and he's killing people even a toy
car somehow apparently kill the dog you
explain that one
Wow that ended abruptly it's almost like
Stephen King look this scene over and
said no K an ice cream truck in a walk
or are the villains in this CN n yeah
this is stupid
let me tell you right now boy and girl
but I guess that can't be as silly as
Christine and friends starting to run
over people at the truck stop you know
it's one thing if machines just out of
the blue came to life but how the hell
is something as random as a comet
supposed to give a soul to modern day
appliances it's like if I dip that
pumpkin hot dog in that pumpkin whipped
cream something evil what happened which
is suddenly right next to me which is
probably cold now so I'll eat it another
day or maybe I'll eat it later today
after the review while talking about the
cinematic version of Stephen King
playing with his Hot Wheels
hey thanks disembodied head to which
your origin I know not hell you have
summoned us critic behold we are the
trope raisers by God I've heard of you
you come from a world where aggravating
pain and Stephen King cliches are one
and the same
you learn to love them after the first
twenty books as you will learn to love
them critic but I don't want to love his
tropes I want to make fun of them but
you must behold Stephen King trope
number one to seven the religious nut
this beautiful American truth way Bible
can be yours for just 995 nagi-chan I
bet he runs into all the redneck
characters right how did you know about
trope number two six four seven because
there's all these characters are either
a country bumpkin or a blood sucking
Christian well surely you don't know
trope number three six four nine eight
the religious nut dies yes that's the
one
well of course he does it happens in all
this movies look are you aware of trope
number three eight five the obvious
symbolism of hypocritical faith maybe
yes yes well just because people accept
a trope over and over and over that
doesn't make it good if anything it
makes it worse you may say that now
critic but just like a Will Ferrell
performance you will learn to love it
hate it love it and then forget you ever
saw it in the first place while look
forward to that part
your defenses will lower critic and I'll
be there when they do so like I said so
like I said before the religious nut is
run over by the toy truck which despite
being an over-the-top drawing of a cloud
it's didn't somehow it gives a more
subtle performance than to curry zero
flirt yeah
everyone tries to figure out what to do
well I think this guy went into a coma
on screen as the trucks actually start
to circle the gas station
nothing more frightening than delivery
trucks playing ring around the pussies
around it's loaded with pods whose IQ is
a tracker I think you'll need some
peppermint schnapps to get through this
movie meanwhile our newly Dead's aren't
having much luck as they're being chased
down by other evil Herbie's a drunk
Frodo dabbles in particular pants
Silvana truckers
yeah hang on while I veered comfortably
to the right
metal ISM
huh I guess that comment made them extra
sensitive to blow up over grassy hills I
know we call the police from that truck
stop up there well it is a truck stop
and we do need to stop trumps
unfortunately the sinister six wheelers
aren't letting up so our heroes go out
to helps Quintus Whittier get inside
what good thing I have them miss on
cloaks and nobody would see it hit the
truck
no I want to see I want to see it by god
she's to find her social class where'd
you get all that stuff oh we got a whole
bunch
just keep circling don't let them know
it bothers us
so let's reveal that under the truck
stop there's a shit ton of firearms that
they never knew about good thing those
machines weren't somehow effective I
mean seriously
there's a gun that starts shooting off
later and yet somehow none of these
devices are affected by the comet what
sense does that make
there's a reason that guns are to live
some machines are affected more slowly
those with simpler parts and mechanics
wait a minute wait a minute is this like
justifying the clown and the spider and
it with this complicated backstory with
really Stephen King just wanted a reason
to use a clown and a spider in it no the
spider and it is really plain and simple
to understand oh yeah what is it there's
a void surrounding the universe known as
the macro versus resentence isn't even
over and already I can't follow it no
really it's super easy to follow I'm
surprised it left it out of the movie
it's natural enemies the turtle
well not just any turtle the turtle that
created the universe and others but
that's another really easy story to
follow we'll be right back after this
common sense explanation takes place and
the next thing we knew Master Splinter
raised them and they developed a machine
by of course Donatello because he's the
smartest one everyone knows that
from the mountains to the oceans in the
great state of Maine everything you need
is here unless you skip the ad that will
take you there or that's what happens
when you don't give in to Stephen King
tropes
all has become commercials for Maine for
Biola we stopped explaining how those
jokes are genius and just like people
watch the video
not until you hear how many great scenes
were left out of his movie adaptations
like how the original ending of Carrie
had a meteor shower that sounds stupid
it was better the way he wrote it or how
the girl in it had have sex with all the
boys in order for them to survive that
sounds awful and stupid it was better
the way he wrote it and don't forget the
electrically charged condoms did not to
pupil well it was that or the way he
wrote it well can't just enjoy the
terrible tropes in this film for now so
you are enjoying it just let me watch it
so as the Sun Goes Down and the trucks
continue to circle the place there's
only one logical thing to do pork I'll
tell you one thing what's that
you should make like here what can I say
being held hostage by an army of six
wheelers just turns me on even though
most of the people seem to be pretty
relaxed while these trucks do nothing
but keep circling the wagon are these
things even supposed to be scary it's
turning the sky green somehow supposed
to make them even more threatening
it's like watching dozers let's talented
sister bulldozer the goes Aryans drunken
simply ain't going anywhere until she
gets a bottle of Wild Turkey Wild Turkey
bitches I needed my sisters dead killed
by some babies to mediate sighing oh
yeah I need some ibuprofen but one
waitress decides she's done taking it up
the tailpipe dear it's time for our
ceremonial stephen king actor turns into
cartoon character again
she's moving like a Jerry Lewis
animatronic with extra William Shatner
parts look hi all you cats we made you
don't make a circle around you some more
well back to our all-important drinking
you know when you take the homicidal
element out of it they actually kind of
treat it like a nice situation Ford
truck should try to kill them more often
this was one of the most relaxing times
they've had in years but they hear the
religious nut outside making noise and
because we all clearly know he has a
chance to make it out of this alive they
tried to sneak out and go after it
Wow the comet must have also messed with
how flashlights weren't because it's a
little confused what's supposed to be
late and what isn't
but before they can get to the guy the
little boy comes across him first
yeah he gets up he gets up he gets up
well gee I guess you really fooled me
movie I guess he's not going to get up
no really
you totally got me I'm totally convinced
that he is not gonna get up and do a
jump-scare whatsoever well I might as
well go do some OHS does he know he's
clearly not getting up you really got me
there movie really happy
do all dying Christians sound like the
bad guy from Howard the Duck the team
does meet up with him and tries to drag
him back but again big shocker he
doesn't make it all the way thus they
use what they should have been using
this whole time a fuck ton of weapons
it's not like they have a whole shit ton
of them at their disposal all Batson -
wait
they hide inside again as the kid
discovers his father has in fact passed
on where's my dad oh dude got scooped by
one of the big boys out there hey just a
little lesson in manners from the road
twitch don't make me lightly slap you
like I'm swatting a fly on your chinny
chin
well he got over that fast fucking
bubbles but some armed equipment finally
makes its way to the stop and starts
letting loose
oh no not the extraneous characters they
offered so much and a little they
offered
oh dear somebody spilled jam on the in
between shots why didn't anybody tell me
that jerk never survives a Stephen King
story yes she needs to relive her
oscar-winning moment hi yes she just
took the bazooka for moral support
dancing the work the gun starts honking
Morse code which apparently none of the
other trucks could have honked but even
more amazingly one of them actually
knows how to interpret it incredible
they want us to feed him feed him that's
right of everybody all they wanted this
entire time was just fuel really there
was no other way they could have made
that obvious wouldn't have been easier
if they just did something like this in
fact isn't driving around constantly in
a circle wasting their goddamn fuel your
fucking wasting your lifespan trying to
get it your lifespan I just wanted
someone to do Stephen King right oh well
they also come to truck home syndrome
and decide to fill them all up Amelio
let's the lead truck know by literally
whispering into its ear sarn't you
bastard
tell all your friends main lines open
I'm sorry I just don't think I can take
a scene seriously when he's whispering
into what looks like a mask Happy Meal
toy I got the best shit on these curves
practically uncut the fuel gauge Emilio
first you start with the fuel
this results in literally hundreds of
other trucks hearing the news somehow
when showing up as well to get fueled up
yep it's about as stupidly silly as it
sounds
imagine your your race aliens right
you're looking for a place to live
dude you filled up trucks not survived a
war I think it can be a little less
dramatic about it said in there for a
change that's right
well that's an interesting Lee stupid
theory but like the credit said comet
which makes much more practical sense is
kind of not really but I'm sure it's
explained in Dark Tower or something so
only now do they decide to figure out a
plan to take these suckers out and leave
whoa cool champ little Pete business
take care of something you wouldn't
understand
now when I say run you run okay I know
we don't have ears but we've clearly
established I can hear you guys it's the
same volume you were speaking to me just
a minute ago oh my god if I just easy to
take out you've got to be kidding me
put the fucking foil by
user-friendliness they wait until night
to make their escape as for some reason
the trucks let them do it until several
hours later when they finally decide to
attack the place brilliant planning wait
until your enemy has fled and then let
them have it coach
they're even crushing the newlyweds car
that an only now realizing never came to
life again explained in dark tower I'm
sure
again spider-man but wait what's that
Beth we're never having the midget
turtle bars
I need my gumdrop eyes they head towards
the votes because apparently they're not
affected by the comet alien goes
whatever but Yoda from hell is still
ready for some action you think that can
stop me I'll wait I'm done yeah good job
oh so was aliens okay the comet uh
barely had nothing to do with anything
in fact it didn't even pass over by the
time all this stuff took place mmm what
a twist
yes the king has often known for twists
as it is trope number two really just
two they don't all have to be big nose
so have you succumbed to the Stephen
King tropes and all its trophies
actually yeah I kind of have so you know
what it means to love repeatable pay no
actually I love them for a different
reason
in my opinion this is Stephen King's
version of of evil a film that's meant
to be over the top fan I don't think he
wanted to scare us with this I think he
wanted to make us laugh I mean let's be
honest no film using ac/dc
is intending to scare anyone in the
strange way I think he's not only
mocking horror tropes but his old tropes
as well when he says I just wanted
someone to do Stephen King right maybe
he's referring to the fact that he's
never meant to be taken too seriously
there's always a bit of otherworldly
insanity that even he can poke fun of
and lab at so as a totally crazy cliched
explosion filled bloodbath of idiocy
it's a damn fun time I mean okay it's
not for everyone it's pretty mindless it
just has a bunch of big explosions but
truth be told
I kind of recommend it if you're looking
for something that's bizarrely silly
over-the-top and soaked in
testosterone-filled cheese and this is
the perfect Stephen King b-movie for you
so what do you think of that I think I
got bored halfway through your speech
Thanks
let us instead analyze the overuse
tropes of the United a Caprio lives oh
now that sounds like fun
let's see truck number one he's always a
smug and or insecure douche truck number
two ridiculous accent number three
screaming in that ridiculous accent
trope number four hey that's my favorite
prop dressing up like an older man even
though he looks 15 oh hold a second mmm
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and nostalgia
we met just begun
okay truck number five mine Scorsese
trope number six Martin Scorsese chum
number seven trying his best to have you
remember a performance by screaming
yelling and crying all in the same scene
directed by Martin Scorsese guy goes
without saying this is fun
paradise
yeah